what's happening there reject nation
greg and john here today to watch the
epic easter eggs breakdown from new rock
stars for spider-man no way home you
knew this was coming peyton fun fact uh
we waited around all day for this on
saturday and then we had friends coming
over little friends gathering 8 p.m
rolled around when this dropped for us
and we spent 20 minutes in this room
going do we
staying here for the next three to four
hours working on this race at christmas
time or do we wait for this and do it
now so sorry for getting this to you
guys late but we're here now this is
coming out on monday so keep a lookout
for our spoiler talk which is going to
be going live around 11 30 a.m pacific
center time live stream genre was
supposed to be joining us but it's
looking like he's not going to be able
to because he's been pretty pretty sick
still trying to narrow down what it is
it's a bummer because the guy literally
introduced both john and i to both kevin
feige and
to focus he's like oh man i really
wanted you here dude why don't you tell
some stories and stuff
but here we are today let's see what's
in store this will help prep us for the
spoiler talk even more
[Music]
welcome back to new rock stars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of
spider-man no way home a true
spider-verse event that start to finish
is a love letter to the web slinger's
full cinematic history not only by
bringing back past peter parker's
but in even subtler ways echoing little
moments that prove how despite all these
guys different backgrounds these dorks
were destined across paths and rescue
each other i love that break this scene
by scene for everything you might have
missed and folks i think i found more
easter eggs in this movie than i have in
anything i've ever broken down on this
channel in five years the breakdown's
finally here yeah really quick what i
want to add is that one thing i was
thinking about on the car right back
home to film mr john it's so cool how
now that toby mcguire and andrew
garfield films feel like essential
viewing for the marvel cinematic
universe because before it was like no
you don't really need to watch them
they're great but you don't need to
watch them now they're like no to really
get the full marvel cinematic universe
experience you must watch these love
that the opening marvel studios title
card has been updated slightly so that
if you look closely on the whole of the
r replacing rocket who's in recent mcu
titles is now peter parker the moment he
came back through that portal to join oh
interesting this movie will also make
grown men cry seeing spider-man arrive
through portals twice so we open
immediately where far from home left off
the audio of the news broadcast of j
jonah jameson's daily bugle revealing
peter parker's identity by mysterio's
doctored footage director john watts
recreated that 2019 scene to near
perfect detail before ended by cutting
off peter's f-bomb
which itself was a callback to aunt
may's final line in
but now homecoming car horn sensors out
the word and mj is once again in her
joan of arc shirt but the three extras
behind her are dressed exactly like the
three guys behind mj in the far from
home scene but the one major difference
is that mj now wears the broken black
dahlia necklace that peter bought her
and venison gave to her in london
i actually like it better broken this
necklace is the key to peter and mj's
relationship because in the final scene
despite her memory of peter being erased
something compels her to keep worrying
about
whoa i didn't notice that
dude
i noticed she was worrying if i didn't
connect it that is why that was worth it
alone it was so early on
whoa
it always drew my eye but yeah i never
connected that like oh she would need to
have a reason to wear it yeah i mean
it's a design that she was clearly
always drawn to hence why peter got it
for her but it's gotta be some that's
like the greatest clue that there's
something in her subconscious that
remembers him oh that was great over for
a ride proof that she wasn't just with
peter because he was spider-man and that
she will wait forever for that i love
you because she likes things better
broken notice how what the onlooker says
you're just a kid just like one of the
onlookers on the train says in
spider-man 2 when that peter got
unmasked he's just a kiss
just a kid peter swings mj through times
square where jameson's inescapable
broadcast includes an image of peter's
face half covered as it often is in the
spider-man comics and they passed two
billboards for rogers the musical the
captain america musical from hawkeye on
disney plus peter lands mj on the
queensboro bridge where they are spotted
by passengers on the nearby roosevelt
island tramway famous from the 2002 sam
raimi spider-man film as the setting of
the play yeah yeah absolutely peter
choose between mary jane or sather the
children and then right after getting
that toby error reference we get an
andrew garfield error reference when
peter whips the manhole cover recalling
the very last time we saw andrew oh yeah
yeah yeah
cool who means peter's favorite spot
that showed up in homecoming and in a
deleted scene apart from home but notice
how it now reads del mar's three for
this being the third tom holland
spider-man movie oh my god you know what
i just realized right now the beginning
of this movie peter's swinging away from
something escaping from something and
the very end of the movie he's swinging
towards himself
that's great storytelling like you
really usually why you're like opening
shot to mirror but beat the difference
yeah you represent the growth of things
trying to get away from the present and
then he's swinging into the future by
the end oh that's great i love it
absolutely love it back in their
apartment it made dumps happy oh but
then they walk in on mj and peter d
clothed calling back aunt may walking in
on peter and ned just like this in
homecoming but john watts shoots all of
this in a full two-minute long take i
love it and that awkwardness and kudos
to these four actors because the timing
is so precise like when peter gets to
work the window shade the first time he
then slips it shut which feels
improvised like tom holland screwed up
closing it the first time but then it
was just like oh peter could flip it and
then they added in the vfx webbing after
that also notice how peter wears the
same i survived my trick
yeah that he wore in homecoming as he
came back home after mr stark
confiscated his suit it's less baggy on
him now because our little guy is grown
up the daily bugle broadcasts hammer
away at peter you see a daily news front
page photoshopping mug shots using their
yearbook photos and revealing mj's name
as michelle jones watson for the first
time adding the watson like her
counterpart mary jane watson time
magazine calls him iron man junior and
shows him crying like a baby in touch
weekly calls him too faced and then
peter gets doused in green paint while
newsreel footage of tower bridge
includes the ticker political turmoil
continues in new asgard huh so i guess
valkyrie's rule over that colony in
townsburg norway might be a bit unstable
something we could see more of thor
loving thunder setup
far from home linking them to stark
giving investigators grounds to arrest
peter the dodc returns department of
damage control who cleaned up avenger
messes and homecoming now led by agent
cleary albert cleary is the dodc
comptroller in the comics
photos showing a framed photo of ned and
mj from the homecoming dance interesting
how peter is not in that picture though
keep that in mind we see peter star wars
figurines there's a photo taken of the
iron spider charging station without the
suit in it though and you see all that
tangle of plugs into that one wall
outlet also we see the edith glasses
that mysterio was trying to steal from
him and a bunch of playstation games
because sony he for everyone got
irresponsible peter still is
just put my eat of glasses right here on
top of my playstation games is that a
batman game it is a batman is that
hitman hitman or batman i think it might
actually be hitman just because of the
way that this letter looks maybe he's
found a way to jack edith into the game
like not like an oculus or something
right here yeah i'll put it in a safe
parent with my playstation please
during the interrogation peter where's
the physics or theoretical but the fun
is real shirt that he wore in spider-man
homecoming when tony stark dropped him
off back in queens asian cleary says
fury's been off planet for the past year
so peter thought he was talking to fury
during far from home but he was actually
talking with the skrull talos also
confirming that the dodc is more aware
yeah
that's very true
also that agent cleary just made my list
of suspicious
yes how else what do you know stark
industries the company itself gets swept
up in the investigation so uh oh i guess
morgan starts gonna have to go to public
school the file phone the use of happy
hogan was his look from iron man 3
prologue in 1999 when he had long hair
and bolo tie like vincent vega and pulp
fiction and blowing our minds in the
first 10 minutes they get legal counsel
from freaking charlie cox matt murdock
daredevil from the netflix series a
crossover even crazier than toby and
andrew in my book because a this is
permanent in the mcu and b it presents
wilder implications for the mcu
suggesting that much if not all of what
we saw in the netflix marvel shows could
now be mcu canon and we just saw cox's
co-star vincent d'onofrio appearing as
kingpin in hawkeye and that finale
episode will apparently give us some
clarity on the exact canonicity of all
those stories but to be clear this matt
murdock is the super power daredevil a
brick flies in through the window and he
catches it with lightning fast reflexes
but i love how peter's hand was also
ready to catch that brick too since he
has spidey sense also fun fact john
favreau played foggy nelson in the dead
cool also fun fact not only john favreau
but john campio's photo proven real
very moment yes it's a good day for
john's and spider-man you guys know how
much i've supported save daredevil i
really hope that it's not a variant even
though you would say that toby maguire
and the andrew garfield ones are
essentially variants of peter parker
their story lines that we witnessed are
still now canon and that's what happened
and that's the background of those
versions and i would like that to be the
same for them is that we experienced
those charlie cox vincent d'onofrio's
stories and i want that to be the same
when moving forward yeah i feel like
that's what makes it special about
getting those actors back is all that
bonding we did with their iteration of
the character yeah i know some people
are totally fine with it being two
variants for the ones we don't like yeah
so they have to move into happy's condo
where he swiped tony's dumb e-robot that
we saw in the first iron man film also
recovered in iron man 3 and we saw happy
yelling at it in homecoming now first on
the tv there are some people complaining
about the new changes to the statue of
liberty which i agree why would you add
cap shield do it also while they're in
the car
by the door he has a bunch of spare
security badges hanging this is after he
lectured everyone in iron man 3 that
they have to have their one badge on
them at all times as peter and mj
facetime in mj's room hangs her sketches
of peter with a rain cloud over his head
but also that one of coach wilson from
homecoming why are you here you don't
even have detention oh i know i just
like coming here to sketch people in
crisis oh yes
there's also that same photo of her
again without peter in it and a photo of
pigeons and venice and on the bed behind
her she is reading maya angelou's i know
why the caged bird sings in this
conversation peter mentions his spider
bite ever since i got bit by that spider
i've only had one week where my life has
felt normal this is actually only the
second time in the mcu that peter really
referenced that now after his
you got chat stands
a spider can it bite me betty brandt
hosts the midtown morning news still a
job that she apparently also balances
with being an intern for the daily bugle
and tick-tock and she says go get him
tiger marry jane's catcher peter in the
comics and in the past films also you
can hear some of the crowd yelling do a
flip just like yeah yeah
i noticed on the second time
the protesters signs include several
pro-mysterio ones one calling peter
devil in disguise so this movie's
premise is loosely based on the
spider-man one more day comic in which
peter goes to doctor strange in search
of a spell to make everyone forget that
he's spider-man but ends up having to
turn to a little girl who is revealed as
methesto to do this instead it actually
ends with a similar reset as this film
in which peter's identity is a secret
once more but at the cost of his
relationships with mj and with his
friend it was a very controversial comic
when it came out but like many great mcu
movies it turned a pretty divisive comic
story line into a really great work of
cinema yeah in the crowd there's also an
mj supporter this is exciting
which is probably a nod to the dc comics
preceding timeline crossover event with
barry allen meeting alternate versions
himself and a batman which is being
adapted to another cross-franchise event
with the flash in 2022. it really is the
year of multiverses isn't it it is it is
everywhere even 824 is on the train now
really yeah that new michelle yo movie
is a multiverse movie of what called
everything everywhere all the time or
something like that and she's like
dipping into different realities of
herself what yeah i've ever heard
yeah it just dropped like a couple days
ago and now i'm like okay we've had a
couple really cool really awesome
multiverse stories but as the more of
them start to come i'm like oh god how
much crossover similarity are there
gonna be well i think the next big one
obviously multiverse and madness that's
when i think we're finally gonna get
x-men the school's mural of great
inventors throughout history that showed
howard stark in homecoming has also now
added the faces of abraham erskine who
is the inventor of cap super soldier
serum as well as hank pym in the upper
right corner coach wilson mr dell and mr
harrington greet peter with a display
case of peter's academic decathlon
awards and his blazer there's also a
photo of peter and mj in venice where it
looks like mr harrington might have
pasted himself in from one of his
selfies that he took then we met
hannibal burris and jb spooked we did uh
koi introduced us to them they and
we actually no we went up to hannibal
yeah yeah we're giving credit for that
one boy and it's funny because there's a
comedy edge about them that i was like
or they're just gonna make footage they
just kind of rip on it are they gonna be
mean to me they were so nice right now
yeah they look insanely nice super
personable and jv smooth especially
who's usually so weird in interviews
yeah i was like oh you're like a pretty
normal dude actually yeah exactly
or maybe it's just the multiverse
version of it yeah
later on the rooftop mj reads a new york
post that is the salacious tabloid that
they actually based the earlier daily
bugle designs on reading peter parker
and his spider minions showing peter
puppeting ned and mj below reading his
hypnotic spider senses seduced jones
watson male spiders actually do release
hypnosis like pheromones and ironically
peter does allow mj and ned to be
brainwashed but to forget about him
peter rolls over to kiss her and the
textbook that he rested his head on was
chem mystery
i see what you did there
[Music]
[Laughter]
is ditko a reference to spiderman
co-creator steve ditko peter gets
rejected from college afternoon college
dumb e gradually reassembles peter's
death star until the mit woman comes in
and just breaks it just like ned did and
all three of the friends get rejected
which is a bummer because mit is tony
stark's alma mater where he handed out
scholarships in civil war and where
future iron heart river williams goes to
school the witch string lights actually
have little goatees making them little
doctor strangest giving peter the idea
of what avenger to return to and we hear
the notes of dr strange's theme here
that leads peter seven seven eight
bleaker street the sanctum sanctorum no
we can't play the music because of you
know copyright stuff when that music
cute kicked in i felt it both for that
with strange and also the first scene
with when he uh encounters electro
there's this like amblin ghostbusters to
vibe about it that mystic wonder quality
yeah in different shades though too
because yeah like the doctor strange
music is very much like yeah we're gonna
go into a dungeon somewhere and then the
electro music has like this almost
dubstep equality i love it yeah it's a
different flavor than both doctor
strange and also for spider-man inside
one of the shoveling apprentices is
played by emily fong who worked
production on infinity war and games
chung chi in black widow wong arrives
and explains how one of the rotunda
gateways open to siberia and led a
blizzard in we saw those gateways in the
2016 film i will say the productions
movie went to an insane amount of effort
to freeze over the sanctum for just a oh
left the door open to siberia gag i'm
wondering with those
floodwaters in the multiverse of madness
teaser this may be a bigger indicator of
this reality destabilizing strange
floats in wearing a columbia university
hoodie colombia's his alma mater we see
another one of these hoodies floating by
the laundry machines downstairs and he's
carrying a mug reading oh for fox's sake
we learned that wong actually holds the
sword
supreme since strange blip for five
years since one division told us that
scarlet witch's powers surpassed those
of the sorcerer supreme that might mean
strange might be even lower on that
sorcerer hierarchy than we thought and
might need her help even more strange
says that peter's request to reverse
time is selfish plus the time stone was
atomized but peter says quote it's not
about me i mean this is really hurting a
lot of people in doing so peter uses the
same words that the ancient one used in
her crucial lesson estranged it's not
about you and so strange agrees to help
him using a spell called the runes of
kafka not sure the spelling but kafka
isn't from any of the comics that i know
of but what wong says the memory wiping
spell travels the dark border between
known and unknown realities suggesting
that to enact the spell you have to kind
of bridge with other realities of the
multiverse and he leaves them through a
portal you can see that bell tower in
the background that's actually in the
camartage courtyard you know what's
funny about that scene when we watched
in the trailer a lot of us were like
there's something up with strange
because they use completely different
takes while be like don't test that
smell
i won't wink to peter yeah yeah but in
that scene you actually get a rather
unusual side of strange like a really
compassionate side of him yeah he seems
like he's a normal supplement he clearly
sees how distressed peter is there's his
partner's like oh no it's i want to help
you like he's he saw it become a softer
yeah he really is like he has that uncle
vibe where he's like oh man i want to
help you out yeah
yeah ed wong is definitely more like dad
in that scenario yeah but he's not even
as like don't cast that's like look i
want nothing to do with this but he
clearly isn't like super insistent after
a certain point yeah
if you know what you're doing i can't
strange explains how the sanctum is
built at an intersection of cosmic
energy currents that they weren't the
first to seek this out with walls
thousands of years old and that they
shot an episode of the equalizer there
in the 80s the spell goes crazy and
peter shouts basically everyone who knew
that i was spider-man before should
still know that is the rule by which
characters get warped into this reality
also suggesting that kirsten dunst mary
jane both harry osborn several others
might have also been briefly walking
around in the mcu
is that venom
is that james franco soon must have
known that peter is spider-man though i
didn't know when elektro found out that
peter was spider-man unless there's some
kind of spider-man mandela effect that
i'm suffering from it's possible
ah that does raise the question strange
sees a glowing silhouette that looks
like the glowing arms of doc ock him
being one of the characters that are
currently spilling into this reality so
strange has to encase this spell in a
prism similar to how strange and what if
in cases killmonger infinity and zola
ultron in a prism to contain that
reality rupturing chaos but this prism
is a dodecadron which is made up of
pentagons with five sides and five
corners because peter changed his spell
five times
what an attention detail mj for ned for
aunt may for happy and then for everyone
who knew that's five so what was the
sixth well the six may have been a
secret change by dr strange so that he
would still remember peter because he
loves him at least that's my theory
to glide the bridge and inside his
head's up display you can read up in the
corner edith offline also the voice is
changed to mail and that's because the
odc is confiscated and disabled all the
drone network it's interesting that they
did not take this iron spider suit too
but again when they raided its place
that suit was not charging in the port
so i don't know maybe peter tried to
flush the nanotech down the toilet now
on this bridge there are a ton of
license plates and i can tell you folks
i looked at all of them because john
wants to easter eggs in his license
plates the only ones i could actually
decode mean anything were a nissan with
s-e-y-s-1 dp and earlier there was an
anagram book on peter's shelf so this
plate rearranges to spideys
being in this movie and of course the
mit woman's car is 63 a 5 m 3 or 63 asm
3 for 1963 amazing spider-man number
three debut of doctor octopus who
arrives in the scene played once more by
alfred molina from the 2004 spider-man 2
he looks awesome composer michael
giacchino samples danny elfman's doc
theme from that film and as his claws
smashed through this bridge note that
the claws light up red which in that
2004 film was how we knew when the claws
were controlling otto's brain so this
must have happened before peter
converted him at which point the lights
flickered back white doc ogg brings up
his machine here his fusion device that
he was working on in the movie what have
you done with my machine and he quotes
his line from the 2004 film his whole
goal the power of the sun
in the
palm of my hand why are dog socks
clothes different yeah that's a good
question when did he have time to grab
that turtleneck
i mean look at that yeah that's
different than what he's right now yeah
he might have just broken into some
store and stole some stuff you know
typical bad guy action hero time
traveler we've all seen the terminator
movies yeah he pulled it
did a quick change in the smoke grab the
first thing fits perfectly yeah yeah
just wear a leather jacket here maybe
it's just open but it is the turtleneck
yeah but he had his his neck exposed
yeah exactly where did the turtleneck
where's the turtle
mysterio was right now at one point
you'll notice peter webbs one of the
claws to a car door to make it harder
for dock to grab anything else to throw
at him doc ock pries off some of peter's
nanotech which then absorbs onto his
arms so if you remember back to the
first raimi film norman osborne was an
expert on nanotech i'm something of a
scientist myself
i read all your research on
nanotechnology really brilliant and in
the sequence you should be myself he's
building his arms using oscorp tech i'd
like to thank harry osborne and ozcorp
industries for providing it and he
explained how he controls these arms
using a neural link these smart arms are
controlled by my brain through a neural
link
nanowires feed directly into my
cerebellum and since the stark nanotech
is controlled nearly as well that would
allow doc aux tech to be compatible with
it however that link goes both ways so
peter is able to pair with the arms and
control the arms remotely and then otto
snaps at his arms saying listen to me
calling back what he said at the end of
the 2004 film listen to me now then
green goblin swoops in but doctor
strange portals them back to the crypt
where the lizard is already contained
doc ock asked strange if this is a
birthday party just like tony stark
referenced dr strange's jimmy kimmel bit
when they first met oh yeah besides
peter enlists mj and ned ned asked
doctor strange how did you know you were
made of magic because my nana says that
we have it in our family and sometimes i
get these tinglings in my hands you
should talk to your physician aha and
later nana's home has a display noticed
that blades
successfully operates the sling ring
which surprises strange so yes it really
does seem like ned might have a future
as a sorcerer in the mcu well i did
notice too when he does say uh because
ned is a name but then what peter says
oh what about ned did it when they're
doing the spell he holds it whatever
he's holding yeah and like that really
ornate and he's texting he always stood
out to me that he says what is it what
is that
as if there's something different about
this person you name because it's the
only name that jumps off it's gotta mean
something and i don't know if it's just
it was just a joke like what is a ned
because they kind of play it that way
but it might be just throw you off but
yeah he does draw attention to it he
holds it and he does question it yeah as
a what not who what is a ned how do you
define a ned why is that there's all
kinds of creepy goodies a doll turns its
head at them in the fridge are a bunch
of creatures a floating eyeball in a jar
a claw creeping out from under foil mj
finds a goatee guard that strange must
use to get his goatee perfectly shaved
and then mj goes on tick tock to find
people on homemade gliders replicating
green goblin another with a frost giant
cosplay that reads i am the green elf
and then at the end of this they're
finally able to track down electro
repeater also finds sandman battling
electro with his suit turned inside out
salmon helps peter because they were on
good terms at the end of the 2007 film
but electro jamie foxx now has a new
body looking a bit cooler and while dr
connors later calls it out they didn't
know each other while they worked at
oscorp in the same continuity this new
body is never really explained in the
movie meanwhile willem dafoe norman
osborne my favorite actor in this movie
argues with his goblin helmet just as he
would in the 2002 film but the argument
ends with him shattering the helmet but
even after it shatters the goblin voice
laughs meaning breaking that helmet did
not destroy the identity it just fused
it into norman's soul yeah you see i i
totally believe that because of the fact
that when you first see goblin on the
bridge he shows up as green goblin yeah
mask on he's laughing maniacally yeah so
it's almost as if the goblin was like no
i'm going to let you do this thing you
get to know the world we're in but i'm
still here the whole time i'm going to
take over when the time is right i'm
collecting information in the background
so i can make this as painful as
possible yeah
notice the framing of this broken mask
as norman walks away matches the framing
of toby maguire peter leaving his suit
behind in the garbage can
but in both cases the characters get
dragged back into the game peter returns
to the beast facility that's the
homeless center where peter works in the
streets
someone tagged the sign outside with
mysterio was right in a green circle
over peter's head just like mysterio's
fishbowl helmet inside norman plays a
convincing mentally disturbed man saying
someone's at my house ozcorp doesn't
exist my son no oscars off referring to
harry osborn of course but also telling
us that oscorp at least any company
named that is not currently in the mcu
anywhere there is an oscorp in the
morbius universe there is which is
probably connected to venom and we did
see a spiderman poster in there so
whatever the hell is going on with that
spider right here
so it is becoming confusing to me well
yeah because half the spiderman stuff
they have is is akin to the tobey
maguire universe too but it doesn't seem
like it's exactly in that universe
either it looks like it's in the andrew
garfield yeah
yeah notice how he wears a green coat
over those purple sweats goblins colors
meanwhile aunt may's costume is worth
looking at she's wearing a blue jumper
with a red sash it could be
foreshadowing the bloody wound that
causes her death aunt may tells peter to
help a woman peter says this isn't my
problem which she gets mad at him over
because it recalls toby mcguire peter's
fateful decision nuts it's a good twist
uncle ben's death i missed the part
where that's my problem j jonah jameson
upgraded daily bugle show which is
really thanks to his spider-man coverage
now pushes supplements which is another
jab at alex jones the chiron reads why
does spider-man hate national monuments
they're calling the washington monument
and homecoming and tower bridge apart
from home i gotta say what they did with
jay jonah jameson and this one i think
is excellent when you cut him in the
raimi films he's really just funny like
that's the main purpose of him being
there yeah he's a nuisance
is his weight on peter's back but at the
same time he's mainly like he's funny
he's funny when he shows up when we
first see him here yeah he's got funny
parts but as he progresses you really
see like he is that like threatening
voice of news personality yeah yeah you
really see he is this dark echo of a
voice in peter's life and in
spider-man's life especially too it's
like in the tobey maguire movies and
stuff and and you know it's different in
the andrew movies like it doesn't seem
like j jonah jameson's slander libel i
should say in the papers is as effective
on spider-man as is on just peter's
emotional state whereas here it's like
all the movies about him just tearing
apart the image of spider-man like when
he gets on in the van to go find him oh
he's a villain well it asks you because
of the fact that it's in you know it's
on a big old screen it feels like it's
so much more present than in a paper
otto octavius recalls the moment he
warped saying he had spider-man by the
throat so this must have happened right
before toby changed him in this moment
in the film these things have turned you
into something you're not
don't listen to them so it's my dream
where'd he get the caller next
that's right we have to be steady and
give up the thing we want the most even
our dreams
you're right
meanwhile max talks about being absorbed
into the grid about to turn into pure
energy we're calling the amazing
spider-man 2 when peter and gwen
hardwired elektro to that grid and
overloaded his chip and then lizard asks
max if he dies but he never gets an
answer and that's because lizard doesn't
actually die in the 2012 film he ends up
locked up and approached to join a
future sinister six they don't establish
at what point in time dr connors comes
back right not really they don't
establish a lot with him
they definitely don't to say when at
what point in time he does come through
as you see an amazing spider-man he he
gets cured filled with shame for what
he's done yeah remorse that's
interesting they didn't really give a
[ __ ] they didn't
here we go so strange shows them the box
the machina dica thomas in latin roughly
the division machine which you can use
to send them back to their universes but
peter and strange debate over this
strange says in the grand calculus of
the multiverse their sacrifice means
infinitely more than their lives the
subtext of course being his guilt for
sacrificing tony stark as part of his
complex calculus from seeing 14 605
future outcomes to defeat thanos if you
think about it calculus was also the
type of arithmetic on he who remains
chalkboard and i just find it
interesting that peter overcomes strange
by doing simpler geometry it's still
super nerdy just not overthinking it
doing as much 4d chess as those guys are
so peter snatches the box and strange
pursues him trapping him between portals
so that he whips himself
i love it but then he brings peter back
to push his astral soul from his
physical body similar to how the ancient
one did to him however peter's soulless
physical body still manages to evade
strange
interesting this must be a higher form
of the spidey sense which would be a
neurological reflex that is divorced
from peter's conscious mind but also
shows us how this is really linked to a
kind of metaphysical magic and later in
the movie andrew garfield peter does say
magic's real here too so he might be
aware of that link as well oh
i thought he was just saying because
they were getting caught up in the
science of it all of like the multiverse
string theory is real and yeah this
theory
magic's real here too i thought i meant
like oh it's also here not in the my
universe there's also magic yeah there's
in addition to these crazy things also
magic because his universe didn't have
all that crazy stuff that's here in the
mcu universe that's what i thought of it
i mean there's like very few super
powered people even why would they also
be back strange sends the cloak of
levitation after peter giving us that
what if spider-man became the sorcerer's
supreme image from the comics that we
also saw in the zombie episode of what
if i love this detail on a nearby
newsstand are people magazines with liz
allen peter's crush from spider-man
daughter to adrian toombs
strange traps peter in the mirror
dimension the vfx are incredible peter
tumbles past the high line in new york
city which kate bishop actually just
recommended to elena in hawkeye he
tumbles through a department store where
you can hear christmas music playing
that actually kind of reminds me of the
opening of spider-man miles morales game
when he's riding rhino and they're going
to the mall and his christmas team and
stuff that's my little my little my
little nugget of information peter
tumbles toward the bethesda fountain in
central park actually looks like the
angel of water statue might have like
the statue of liberty been swapped out
for an avenger strange traps peter in an
endless loop of portals creating the
illusion of infinite spider-men as there
are and then peter recognizes from the
archimedean spiral that he can geometry
the [ __ ] out of this and trap strange in
a web of math and again if you want a
way to really celebrate this awesome
magic vs math moment you gotta get your
hands on our exclusive strange intimate
image called dibs
to help people i'm going to get the red
very scientists myself of course this
line from the 2002 movie you know i'm
something of a scientist myself peter
and ned do their recurring handshake and
it ends with the sling ring sparking a
bit a little sign that ned does have a
kind of inner magic to him peter takes
them to happy's condo the security feed
glitches as electro passes from his
interference and then auto snaps i don't
need fixing especially by some teenager
using scraps and a bachelor's drunk
drawer so it's not a drawer full of
scraps it's uh
on the walls of happy's room you can
actually see the name slot that's a
reference to longtime spider-man writer
dan slott peter activates the stark tech
fabricator we saw this kind of device
used on the stark jet to design his new
suit and far from home you know what i
love about this
just hit me at this moment
eric had to comb through this looking at
cam footage yeah
at shitty degraded footage that somebody
did
out of their jacket somewhere in a
theater with lack security
so proud of me to be like man it's a
beautiful looking film you have to do
this amazing easter egg breakdown
frame by frame on like shitty ass watch
it through a muddy window it's powered
by an arc reactor this is a familiar
design this is the new element arc
reactor mark one with the triangular
inlay that tony stark constructed using
the new element he rediscovered in iron
man 2. i love that this is the era of
arc reactor he used because in
spider-man homecoming they specifically
had the mark 42 armor that was using
that same generation of arc reactor from
iron man 3 on the stark jet so that
would be the one that happy still has in
his possession meanwhile otto and may
share some water in the kitchen they did
briefly date in the comics then peter
designs a new inhibitor trip for doc och
to replace the one that got fried in the
2004 film and he puts in place these six
needles that go into otto's skin and
fuse with the spinal cord i love how
they use the same exact production
design from the rainy films for all of
these pieces of technology they really
clearly did their homework to look at
how all of these things functioned at
this point the red lights on dock's
claws flicker back to bluish white and
he transfers the nano tank back to peter
to give him this golden spider eight
arms just like his own it's like giving
up a badge of honor there otto
encourages his buddy norman that he's
about to rid himself of his darker half
but norman facing away from him says
just me and defoe uses his darker goblin
voice in this moment meaning it is only
goblin in his mind right now and so
peter's spidey sense kicks in and he
just kind of wanders around the condo
it's super creepy
as it begins the first person to appear
in his periphery is norman osborne and
the first thing peter says is may it's
his instinct telling him that norman
will post a fatal threat to may and so
peter whips norman to dummy which as
they came into the condo you could see
norman in the background casing so
goblin makes his case to the other
villains these are not curses these are
gifts recalling the final lines of the
2002 film the lesson that toby maguire
peter learned this is my gift
my curse oh that is
awesome his powers as both a gift and a
curse the fight breaks out peter punches
goblin and goblin just smiles more and
more he is loving it combat is just so
brutal apparently william defoe insisted
on doing as many stunts as he could
himself and downstairs goblin's glider
strikes may and now that creepy face is
covered in a hobgoblin style hood and he
tosses a pumpkin bomb which peter bats
away showing how this goblin is just as
willing to bomb an aunt may as he was in
the 2002 film and as she dies may says
the immortal words of uncle ben with
great power there must also come great
responsibility yeah there was a slight
rewording and that's because she said
the original comic wording of the lion
[ __ ]
directly from stanley oh that is great
ned uses the sling ring to portal to one
of the other peter parker's currently in
this universe spider-man andrew garfield
a guy no one will ever believe again in
interviews pretty god andrew garfield's
still denying him
you should never ever confirm it they
use my likeness
i don't know who that is but they never
call notice the music in this moment is
actually james horner's young peter
theme from the amazing spider-man film
in 2012. and we just gotta pause and
appreciate how great the intro garfield
era of the spider-man suit was i mean
it's definitely my favorite
aesthetically great shade of blue huge
eyes and a true diy practicality to it
one thing that era nailed but then ned
portals again and toby mcguire peter
parker steps in his entrance set to
danny ellison's spider-man theme and we
gotta credit both mcguire and garfield
for so deftly slipping back into their
mannerisms toby is preemptively polite
and dopey andrew is post-mistake
apologetic and super chatty and i also
like how their first instinct upon
seeing each other is to thwhip attack as
if the last time either these guys
encountered a doppelganger it might have
been a hostile situation toby peter says
that he'd like to hang out atop the
chrysler building as we saw his peter
perch in the rainy films andrew peter
says he'd like the empire state building
for the few but they find peter on the
rooftop of his school in queens it's not
about the view it's about a refuge from
his high school life you see never moved
into the city andrew peters starts to
say he has some understanding of losing
someone of course referring to letting
gwen stacy die and he goes on to
describe what happened after gwen's
death how he stopped pulling his punches
and got rageful and bitter so apparently
in that garfield continuity this
spider-man might have straight-up killed
people which is an insane revelation i'm
going to explore all that in another
video
to track down uncle ben's murderer and
how in spider-man 3 that wound was
reopened with flint marco and
exacerbated by venom a critical lesson
that he had to learn and all three
recognize the words with great power
comes great responsibility making that
proverb a kind of constant absolute
point among all the spider-man you know
i want to just point out like we did a
video we've done a lot of spider-man
videos but i think that's like probably
one of my top favorite ones we've ever
done where we broke down pretty much
like the 25-minute sequence from the
activation of peter spidey-sense to
after this rooftop scene one thing i we
did not mention out of anything is i
really loved that andrew garfield and
toby maguire were able to be true
supporting characters not just quick fan
service cameos they also seemed to they
didn't want to like outshine tom holland
in the movie that he was able to lead so
it's pretty great that they brought them
back and somehow didn't outshine tom
holland who still this is his movie and
he was still like one of the biggest one
of the main talks was tom holland yeah
and they did it in such a way where two
you feel all of the history just in
those performances to where it does feel
like those movies are important for the
lessons they're imparting on them they
connect with each other and they have
great chemistry that doesn't seem like
it's a competition at all amongst them
no they're all different and that's
perfect it seems like they respect each
other yeah they love it it's and they're
fascinated by each other thank god they
have great chemistry yeah yeah like
they clearly chose the right guy each
time thank goodness they return to the
high school and work together to
engineer cures for all of them i love
how nerdy the second half of this movie
is toby peter tells ned that his best
friend died in his arms after trying to
kill him referring to harry osborn and
spider-man 3 meanwhile toby peter tells
andrew peter that he and mary jane
eventually made it work ned calls for
peter and all three of them look up
confusedly pointed at each other of
course a nod to the meme awesome and
toby peter shows how his webbing unlike
the others whose mechanical web shooters
comes freakishly out of his wrist i love
how andrew plays super grossed out and
even when tom holland moves the
conversation along he even continues
staring at toby's wrist for a beat
before he's like oh okay yeah what and
then on to the showdown at the statue of
liberty toby peter's back tenses up a
callback to peter herding is back in the
2004 film which itself was an inside
joke about how toby nearly sit out of
the sequel after hurting his back on
seabiscuit and then andrew crouch for
him for once cracking someone's backbone
without killing them
of course referring to venom his eddie
brock played by topper grace and setting
up tom hardy venom's arrival in the
post-credits scene and then tom holland
peter talks about how he fought thanos
and she's like i'm lame finally fought a
russian guy in a rhinoceros suit course
referring to paul giamatti's rhino but i
love it toby peter talks him up saying
he's actually amazing giving andrew
garfield the credit he deserves despite
his amazing spider-man era often ranked
the lowest by fans he's still amazing
and now he's got his brothers i'll just
say it man i mean when i did my rewatch
you guys know how religiously in love i
was with toby mcguire but when i did my
re-watch the andrew garfield's shot to
be my favorite one that's been part of
the most fun of the reason is realizing
how much love there is to be had foreign
and even if those films aren't
necessarily the best of the best there's
a lot in there to appreciate but i love
how the first time these feeders try to
work together it totally fails since
they are more used to being solo acts so
while andrew and toby teach tom how to
mourn and to forgive tom teaches them
the one thing his era of smart exactly
that's beautiful cooperation with
superheroes more powerful than he is at
one point toby just understood better
how is this helping and andrew peter
asks if the avengers are a band and
calling back when bruce banner asked
that the avengers broke up like the
beatles the avengers broke up or toast
like a band like like the beatles but
they're able to figure it out and a
little subtle detail here that i loved
during their heroic swing tom holland
peter
whips to his two brothers to sling them
back up with him oh cool
oh no way
liberty head right at electro in sandman
and lizards
see how electro's bolts at one point
fire up in a star shape around his head
like electro's mask
toby peter manages to revert thomas
hayden church flint marco i love how the
device lights up and spins the same way
the super collider did in spider-man 3
then lizard jumps into the portal with
ned and mj thrashing around that science
lab evoking that school battle in the
2012 film but then doc ock helps them
fix electro and they hit lizard with the
same serum gas that they use as the
reigning antidote at the end of the 2012
movie reverting him to rhys eiffen's dr
connors it's funny like marisa eifid's
every time we've seen reese iphone show
up there's always a delayed reaction
with like it's
every time you see it silence you could
just feel the room going dude
uh yeah then there's people eventually
started clapping he's always weirdly
delayed
he changed his voice up a lot but i
guess he's here and i have a question
about jamie foxx that i mean i have some
criticisms about this when i'm kind of
reserving the opinions for the spoiler
talk i do have a question because
there's all this build up about like i
want that art reactor i want the arc
reactor and i honestly didn't see
anything that was truly on display that
made him more powerful other than andrew
garfield saying i've never seen him as
powerful before but i thought he was
more powerful in the amazing spider-man
2 finale fight than
what we saw here i didn't see like why
he craved it so much and what it did
that was so different at least i didn't
physically not in effect no yeah yeah
and max dillon tells andrew garfield
peter that he thought he was going to be
black and that there's got to be a black
spider-man somewhere out there
definitely setting up miles morales to
step up sometime soon hopefully since we
do know from aaron davis's lines in
homecoming that miles morales does exist
in the mcu i don't want those weapons in
this neighborhood i got a nephew who
live here yeah sorry miles i'm not gonna
make it then green goblin dives in
snarling can the spider-man come out to
play calling back his creepy line to
toby mcgregor peter over the phone in
the 2002 film
can spiderman come out to play and he
bombs the box causing the spell to spill
out around liberty island i love how the
vfx caused that tear to turn something
that should be in the deep background
feel like a canvas that is way closer to
us and in this chaos mj slips and falls
from the scaffolding the framing exactly
matching gwen stacy's slo-mo death drop
in 2014 scaring the hell out of all of
us tom holland peter dives after her but
he gets swiped by goblin so it's up to
andrew garfield vader to step up and
catch her redeeming his failure to save
gwen but they do it in a really cool way
because notice this time he focuses more
on the leap itself to catch her in his
arms instead of trying to snatch her
with his webbing all to avoid that
whiplash that actually caused gwen to
die proving that this poor guy has been
obsessing over that decision every day
of his life and that is why he sobs and
relief finally yeah because you even
have like with toby saying like i've
thought a lot about how i could have
saved goblin or something along the
lines of that same same door
yeah so you would imagine that you know
when you're grieving like the especially
in the bargaining stage of like what
what if i had done this what if i had
done that so it's like he instinctually
knew it it's funny because that is like
the most predictable part of like if
badgers in this movie that's what's
gonna happen yet it's so unbelievably
rewarding when it happens yeah yeah
absolutely and i think watching with a
crowd the third time was the best
because mj falls everyone went oh no
don't you do it and then peter leaps and
tom holland was like yeah yeah they
called
we get another little source for our
setup for ned when the cloak of
levitation catches them we actually get
a little light motif of dr strange's
theme music there too get this man a
cloak and then on the fallen giant
captain america shield tom holland peter
and goblin duke it out and it is vicious
peter prepares to kill goblin lifting
his glider to bring down on him the same
way captain america nearly killed iron
man in civil war using the tool that
peter is now standing on this kid is
moments away from going full john walker
but toby maguire peter jumps in grabs
the glider even though tom holland peter
shoves that glider even closer to him
ultimately he helps him see the light
and to make a different choice and so
tom holland proves his change by hitting
norman with the anti-serum making me
tear up again i mean i gotta say it's
also an arc in some ways for toby
maguire's who felt guilt over how that
went down with goblin because in the
first one he gets impaled by his own
glider and he almost got killed by his
own glider again except he was able to
prevent that from happening this time
yeah it's too bad we didn't get a scene
with the green goblin required but i'm
also under the impression they were in
there on set the same day yeah yeah
or at the same even month of shooting
meanwhile the sky opens up to dozens of
glowing silhouettes presumably other
characters who know peter parker is
spider-man from other universes one of
them holds a spear looks like craven the
hunter others match the shape of rhino
there's another one that kind of looks
like a scorpion i'm gonna go deeper into
these in another video too so peter i'm
talking about it
to complete the memory wipe spell as it
was intended meaning everyone will
forget peter is spider-man notice how
whereas the runes before were thinner
more rushed written here they are bolder
and more authoritative like the wounds
cast by scarlet witch in the wanavision
final battle so toby and andrew make
their final goodbyes and toby says it's
what we do recalling how aunt may
justified why you should help people and
peter explains it all to mj and he
promises he will come find her just
reminds me a lot of that theme from
eternal sunshine how love is too
powerful of a force to be bound by
memory and mj tells peter that she loves
him but she doesn't let him say it back
to her way dream that the first time he
can say it to her on the other side
it'll be so pure and real that that
could be the thing that awakens her and
then so after the spell is complete the
world continues to know that spider-man
exists but the name peter parker means
nothing to them this is crazy because it
means that ned and mj still made it into
mit but with no physical evidence of
peter parker's history with them so in
addition to brainwashing everyone's
memories this spell must also have
warped all of reality to you know
documents any kind of digital records
any physical mark that peter parker left
on the world i mean does the guy have a
birth certificate a social security card
how do you get that apartment did you
have to necessitate a new history to be
conjured to replace the theater history
that was erased but and i hate to point
this out but if you think about it peter
was often absent from his major events
in his life from his homecoming dance
from his field trips from his school
competitions he was blipped for five
years it's depressing to realize this
but his erasure is not that disruptive
to his friends lives i mean essentially
this just means mj and ned spent more of
their teenage years alone which for mj
reading a book by herself is just kind
of who she is ned tinkering with his
legos is who he is i mean yeah it's
sadder the more you think about it but
it's true that's why peter makes this
sacrifice because he knows his loved
ones can get by without him and so when
he finds them back in the sorry i have
to make a little bit of a counter argue
you're talking about moments that we saw
in this
over this little brief time span that
we've had with peter parker of like
captured scenes in these like a total of
a few hours of cinema but like he's got
also many years of living before he even
got bit by the spider to factor in as
well and there's still documentation and
records and like so you know they say
like i don't have the time stamps or
can't really really rewrite the past he
doesn't say that like when doctor
strange says doesn't have time some but
there is all this like footage of that
mysterious stuff going around yeah and
all the daily bugle stuff of contacting
peter you know like there's a lot of
this peter parker spider-man you know
even when venom walks it comes joins the
multiverse there's a clear shot of peter
there you know so i think that that's
kind of there it does raise some
questions on how it works is clearly
they are changing time at this point
yeah it changes the timeline and it
rewrites history i think it does have a
major effect if those were the only
memories ever or the scenes we saw then
i'm like sure right what about all the
time before the spider-man ned and peter
have to have pictures together from just
being kids and friends right all the
time in between random guy who used to
be around in their past yeah who now
doesn't exist i guess these questions
don't come up when i watch the movie if
the questions come out when i think
about it when you remember that you have
to be very acknowledged what might be
i'm like so swept up in the emotion of
it and i have questions is all yes and
so when he finds them back in the peter
pan coffee shop himself a kind of peter
pan stuck watching kids grow up and move
on without him however mj still wears
the black dahlia necklace so somewhere
deep down she still loves him in the
coffee cup she gives some reads we are
happy to serve you a cup that he holds
on to to remind himself to serve by the
way we actually saw the sanctum
apprentice with one of those coffee cups
earlier when she was trying to fix that
same artifact that thor also broke
broken ragnarok
that cup also showed up on the dashboard
of the tracksuit mafia in hawkeye oh no
way and peter says
i love you but he stops himself and he
waits upon seeing the band-aid because
he doesn't want to hurt mj anymore so to
protect her for now he walks away it's a
good visual language you'll notice the
flowers cover the birth and death dates
i guess because as tony stark observed
when he first met may in civil war we
never do quite know how old mei is happy
shows up doesn't know who peter is but
he compares this feeling to losing tony
and peter sets up his new apartment i am
praying that they can find a way to make
mr dickovich his name yes you'll notice
he has a ged test prep book and that's
because this guy has no academic record
anymore also we see he sets up his
palpatine lego which was the first we
saw of ned leeds back in homecoming but
that's my question is like does he have
an id card anymore like what is what is
the reach what is spell he's gotta have
some documentation of identity in order
to attend school right yeah or to get an
apartment anyway yeah you know
something he can't get help from tony
starks or stark industries anymore
anything like that because they don't
know him so he's gotta have some form of
identification maybe there'll be a one
take where he goes into the dmv and has
to forge a whole new identity or
something like that because yeah he
doesn't have like all the technology
even anymore so there's gotta be some
recorded history of peter parker i wanna
know what the breadth of the spell is
because yeah it seems like it would be a
lot harder for it to go through every
reach and corner of the universe and
like re-organize pictures documents it's
yeah like when you walk into midtown
hobby like you never attended here oh
wait you did attention yeah you're in
the air book or when the yearbook just
warp and he wears a new suit with
brighter blues and swings out past 30
rockefeller center where the upcoming
finale of hawkeye will be set i don't
think we'll see spider-man swing into
the background of that but a guy can
dream being australian community parker
relied on is so painful but it does
force this kid to mature into the
selfless hero that his forbearers showed
him how to be at times the life of a
hero is a lonely one but all those
people are still there and they may not
remember but they still love him and one
day he will find his way home that is
everything i found in this
heart-wrenching and beautiful spider-man
film but there's so much more i want to
say about this movie so to support our
channel and help us do that please check
out one of those great merch options at
new rockstarsmerch.com that strange
entitlement design is calling to you we
also got a kingpin inspired long live
the king shirt called tips
following you okay subscribe to
rockstars i love my rogers everything
thank you for watching
bye amazing well worth it well worth it
the amazing easter egg man and
unfortunately would not have been able
to appreciate it if people were outside
waiting on us
guys thank you so much for being here
make sure to subscribe to new rockstars
that was a brilliant breakdown from both
eric voss and of course the editors over
there thank you so much for being here
flip flip reject nation more than one
pack catch you guys soon